bella tutti ragazzi benvenuti questo
video sono fa dj oggi siamo su mamma
nostre case cooking mama mamma kills
animals che sarebbe una roba poco
violenta ma veramente poco mi faccio
questa premessa perché bisogna farla
inizio perché se no è una versione di
cooking mama fatta da un'associazione
per far capire che mangiare gli animali
è una cosa orribile
io ci gioco perché mamma agli occhi
belle e quindi ragazzi hanno fatto
questa versione di cooking mama un
pochettino più violenta del solito
ragazzi devo di cucinare come si deve
parlare io vi faccio vedere che la
cucina made by fa vj non muore mai
prepariamo il tacchino spenda il
tacchino clicca sulle piume col tuo
mouse per svelare tacchino va bene
questa cosa
che bello che devo svegliare tacchi ok
ragazzi mi sembra roba esageratamente
sarà già fatta e la manovra ma non marco
avesse infilato il braccio nella gigia
di una col maestro minard e mamma stai
parlando
il becchino e spennato ragazzi a
rimuovere moore a limoni gli organi
interni alla madonna utilizzando il tuo
mouse
rimuovi gli organi interni e va bene ma
sei serio questa truffa o mio dio ma
verame ascoltami devo come finali la
mano nel culo proprio na roba
ok prendo un capitolo trovato pikachu
questo invece è finito ha già c'è il
tempo che [ __ ] non è non essere un
santo come non essere un sound cycling
che se allora prendiamo ste robe
mettiamo macchia schivo le senti che bel
rumore che c'è quando entra la mano
ragazzina o mio dio perché ho avuto un
polmone il fegato
l'ho fatta ho vinto e che cazzo tonight
grazie zia sono un cuoco nato ragazzi
sarà neanche bisogno di specificarlo è
stato veramente una cosa così stufato di
tacchino adesso sbloccato lo stufato di
tacchino fantastico crack di exor ampi
le uova bene rompiamo le uova beh questo
questo lo so fare questo credo di
saperlo fare
scusatemi ragazzi ma mi diverto e forse
cagate quando l'ho un po le uova è una
roba uscite delle piume da una cosa mi
chiama che cazzo di nuova dovrebbero
essere non a caso il tempo tempo il
tempo sono uomo col maestro ragazzi le
classiche uova col maestro sono normali
succede così ascolta zia che cazzo di
vorrei comprato fammi capire
va beh non aprirò mai più nuovo in vita
mia mixa gli ingredienti inserisce
inglese magari la prossima volta compra
delle uova decenti non è possibile così
burro e belle che il burro più bello che
abbia mai visto nella mia vita sembra un
cubo di rubik ragazzi adesso mischio vai
così giro in giro un cazzo è non gira un
cazzo che devo fare
nel colpa mia o mio dio mio dio che io o
mio dio non è bassa come cosa fatta
rifacciamo sa cosa io non è che muovo al
mouse non mischia un cazzo non è colpa
mia io ci provo ma non funziona è stato
che che merda sto mettendo nel toro
spiegatelo ok un altro un altro bravo
ciao ragazzi io sto facendo sì che bello
merda madonna che cuoco che cuoco
miliardi ma va ad are in pizza il
tacchino devo mettere la sbobba dentro
il deretano del tacchino vantarne
poetico devo proprio trascinare la merda
perfetto quebec e bell aspetto che
madonna lo mangerei tre volte ma se ti
arriva l'areoplanino eccolo anche che
merda ragazzi ha cucinato la cosa più
sito minard grazie zia taglia la testa
di serie l'italia più tagliare la testa
ma che schifo ma no ad ariano seriamente
e bruttissimo ma almeno un taglio netto
che alza non così e va bene vale non ci
sono riuscito non sono capace va bene
non essere un santo a madre un santo che
è orribile
quali sono i cavetti quelli delle bombe
taglia filo blu e filo rosso e poi
esplode il tacchino non di open pressing
di andata non devo premere
devo prendere sta cosa
ah sì qua fantastico e quindi devo
toccare lo schermo
l'ho fatto bruciare nyon devo fermarlo
qui giusto fini fremo off quando arriva
ce l'ho fatta miller se grazie mamma
grazie mie possiamo finire cosa complete
e vabbè dai tutti a tavola che fa vj ha
cucinato questa prelibatezza ma anche
cracco che se cio proprio fuoriclasse
pro modestamente potrei aprire un
ristorante ed essere io il cuoco master
adesso lo farà il brodo di pollo per
condire giusto chop chop the knack tagli
al collo anche se ma basta si sentì non
sono capace a false cose tanto ecco non
esploso basta cose che mi fanno schifo
mi fa senso abbiate ecco basta grazie
preferisco tagliare il formaggio molto
più easy non esploso comunque c'è il
consiglio che vi salva la vita tra il
filo rosso e filo blu bisogna tagliarli
entrambi e funziona salt e the body park
prima cosa ragazzi accendiamo il cuore
del cuoco il fuoco del cazzo di voi
mettiamo è il burro perfetto che non è
un burrone un cubo di rubik poi pezzi di
collo polmoni fegato e un po di merda
tutti insieme poi se contiamo con questa
cosa portiamo anche un po la cucina già
che ci siamo e contiamo tutti insieme
poi la padella merda tana [ __ ]
questo è successo trend e grevi cosa
voglio dire cos'è amica che appetibile
che a ragazzi mimetici e due mani lerche
dentro bravissimo e mettici anche il
pene per condire bene non portarle fuori
se cose se pulito a pulita ad esse
pulito adesso è pulito ovviamente se ci
metti della merda dentro e poi la togli
e pulito ma io ripeto se metti il pene
dentro lusi come mestolo game viene
meglio credi complete e ragazzi mistero
è fantastico e se mangio questa roba
nuoro ma muore anche male è stata
l'esperienza culinaria più bella della
mia vita grazie a tema ma ha cambiato
idea ha cambiato a e vegana è diventato
reggiana ma roba eh beh ma come cucino
io ti passa la voglia anche di vivere
quindi va bene ai sbloccato il nuovo
livello mamma love animals marcon
joe black questo mamma nov eni mons
cos'è ea e cucina vegana fontana ragazzi
passiamo al vegano cucino io gira il
tofu ragazzi sono un fenomeno una bella
ravanata dei pantaloni perfetto così
bravo e adesso è adesso tocca tutto il
top per mai così o palpato un tuffo
sulla mia vita e completa better del
mare nel bene che dal gusto andiamo
avanti ragazzi perché shape detto a
fruttare chiedevo amalgamarla tutte
insieme perfetto ma è un pokémon si sta
evolvendo cazzo cos'è stato ragazze gulp
in un poker face detto fu tarchi devo
cucina devo che cosa vuol dire a devo è
proprio diarrea che devo spargere sul ok
che conta che confronta diarrea col
contagocce adesso sta diventando più
pokémon di prima
ho fatta better del mama grazie zia
ragazzi ratatouille una merda i
confronti better than mamma per quanto
hanno fatto la vita sono un fenomeno che
ragazzi non è così oh mio dio è la
madonna dei sommi because of you mamma
lo venimo sera madonna che ne sono
troppo contento ma che caino pucci pucci
che il tacchino così ma sai che primato
tagliato il collo in quattro modi
diversi
voi non sembrare così mongoloide mamma
muovere la testa così per cortesia e
stato un meraviglioso cucinare per voi
avete capito quanto io sia bravo
nell'arte culinaria ai ragazzi proposte
andiamo a fare picnic tutti quanti
insieme tutti ne parco cucino io cucino
io faccio sta cosa che è il mio piatto
forte è più che ragazzi questo eravamo
archi legni mostra che sono una brava
persona molto molto sexy guarda qua
perché sguardi incredible cherchi che
chi mi sto perdendo nel mio naso quindi
ragazzi spero che i video vi sia
piaciuto che cosa sei tu sei video è
cresciuta stato come te mi piace anche
la pagina di facebook e cosa nei video
trovata una descrizione ogni mi piace
che mettete avido un po dove un tacchino
io non sono capace di distinguere gli
animali verrà salvato in più c'è anche
un pokémon in omaggio presidi siate nel
civiltà euro fossero video e ragazzi
[Musica]